[Music]
last saturday the dc fandom took place
one more time like last year the digital
event was able to impress with some
brand new trailers as well as news about
the upcoming dc blockbusters one of the
highlights besides the big titles like
the batman or black adam was the bad
girl series fans were unfortunately not
treated to a trailer but there were
details about the story and the first
glimpse of the super heroine outfit the
concept arc shows the female protagonist
standing on a kind of gargoyle and
glooming gotham city setting
additionally christina hudson chatted a
bit about this story of batgirl
according to her the lead character
whose real name is barbara gordon will
become batgirl only in the course of the
series and as a result she'll be
exploring the duality between the normal
barbara and her other ego batgirl the
team behind the series is definitely
confident and also a little excited as
the two belgian directors adelel arby
and bilal falar reiterated during the
panel the two had most recently directed
bad boys for life we are eager to see
the final result but unfortunately there
is still more information about the
release date
it has been 21 years since one of the
greatest science fiction movies ever
made its theatrical debut of course we
are referring to the matrix franchise
which has had a tremendous impact not
only on cinema audiences but also on pop
culture in general later this year the
fourth installment titled the matrix
resurrections is scheduled to be
released and now that a teaser and a
trailer have already been published
there is more information regarding the
plot much to the joy of many fans the
movie will completely disregard the two
sequels to the original and will take
place directly after part one as can be
gathered from a statement by warner
brothers on their website in addition we
can expect a new and above all much more
powerful matrix than in the first movie
the official description states that
thomas anderson will once again have to
follow the white rabbit the matrix is
described as being stronger safer and
more dangerous than ever before this
sounds exciting and is anything but
surprising since the matrix must have
learned from the events of the first
part and is therefore even more
difficult to defeat we're looking
forward to the matrix resurrections
which is expected to hit theaters on
december 22 2021. what do you think
about the latest news are you content
with the fact that it picks up directly
after the first part or would you have
liked to see more coverage on the events
from the matrix reloaded and the matrix
revolutions let us know in the comments
the john wick series is probably one of
the most popular action franchises of
all time although john wick chapter 3
will be followed by the fourth part of
the movies next year a prequel is also
in production apart from the main series
more precisely the project is a
three-part mini-series called the
continental the plot is set around 40
years before the first john wick part
and focuses on the early life of the
later continental leader winston scott
due to his age 79 year old ian mcshane
will obviously not be playing the young
winston instead 29 year old the perch
actor colin woodle has been cast the
plot revolves around the infamous
continental hotel which the young
winston wants to take over in the 1970s
alongside woodle we will also be
introduced to hollywood star male gibson
in the role of mob boss cormack needless
to say we cannot expect ken reeves to
make an appearance considering that his
story from the film series takes place a
few decades later the series will be
released in three 90-minute episodes and
is scheduled for release as early as
next year
millions of fans around the world are
anxiously waiting the third spiderman
movie starring tom holland which will
come out later this year in addition to
tom holland the marvel multiverse
spectacle is not only expected to
feature three spider-man but will also
feature the return of all villains from
the various spider-man franchises
including the main antagonists dog
electro sandman and green goblin
that being said the movie also marks the
end of the mcu film trilogy from the
friendly neighborhood spider tom holland
commented on this and other details of
no way home in an interview with
entertainment weekly the 25 year old
stated that no way home will definitely
be the end of the series besides he's
looking forward to the revival of the
countless characters from the
predecessors and chances that he found
the shooting of what is expected to be
his last mcu solo film very emotional
with spider-man no way home peter parker
will not only have to face a whole bunch
of villains he will also have to cope
with the fact that the entire world
knows his identity being anything but
well disposed towards him as a way out
of this dilemma he turns to his friend
doctor strange however when the latter
tries to fix the mess things only worsen
at the aforementioned multiverse is
created but not only regarding the story
is their new knowledge because as
various reports suggests we should
finally get to see a new trailer this
month this piece of news comes from an
extremely reliable insider who has often
published reasonable speculations on
twitter under the name spider leaks he
argues with the fact that the uncharted
trailer was released this week making
sony reluctant to promote two big movies
in one week you always have to take such
rumors with a grain of salt of course
but given the circumstances we are
pretty optimistic that the next week
will indeed mark the release of the
second trailer spider-man no way home is
scheduled for release on december 17
2021
one might have thought that the time of
large-scale film postponements had
slowly but surely come to an end
unfortunately this is not the case
because now disney is postponing a whole
bunch of new movies among others the mcu
blockbuster is doctor strange and the
multiverse of madness and black panther
wakanda forever are affected well the
former will now be released on may 6
2022 instead of march fans of black
panther will have to wait an additional
2 months until november 11th fans of
indiana jones 5 will suffer considerably
more however the sequel starring
harrison ford will no longer be released
in the summer of 2022 but on june 30th
2023
that's nearly a whole year later than
last planned other new releases are thor
love and thunder on july 8 2022 the
marvels on february 17 2023 and ant-man
and the wasp quantomania on july 28 2023
disney cites various production delays
as the reason of course this primarily
affects the marvel films which are known
to be linked and build on each other
after tennis star director christopher
nolan is already in the process of
filming his next masterpiece the
blockbuster is to be called oppenheimer
and recounts the story of the atomic
bomb at the very center of the event is
the eponymous u.s physicist robert
oppenheimer who was entrusted with the
management of the infamous manhattan
project during the second world war and
is thereby considered the father of the
atomic bomb this is an extremely
gripping topic that nolan would like to
cover in his upcoming film as of a few
days ago the two main actors have also
been confirmed because while the signing
of cillian murphy is robin oppenheimer
has been known for some time the cast of
the female elite has only recently been
announced the person in question is of
course very familiar to every movie gore
as her name is emily blunt the 28 year
old recently thrilled millions of fans
in disney's jungle cruise and became
world famous thanks to the two acquired
place films at the very latest in
oppenheimer she placed the protagonist
to wife who certainly had a great
influence on her husband's success in
terms of content the movie is based on
the book american prometheus the triumph
and tragedy of j robert oppenheimer
which focuses not only on the work on
the atomic bomb but also in
oppenheimer's private life shooting will
start at the beginning of next year with
the film expected to release on july 21
2023
one of the highlights this week was
definitely their first uncharted trailer
do not hesitate to watch the first
scenes of the video game adaption and
best quality on our channel further do
not forget to keep your eyes peeled next
week because there's a good chance that
we will be able to present the brand new
trailer for spider-man no way home
[Music]